même du ciel on les
aperçoit au large de la Chine dans le
nord du pays des sillons parfaitement
tracés en plein
océan c'est pour ces milliers de petits
points que nous sommes venus
jusqu'ici dans cette baie au bout du
monde à première vue on dira des champs
de mine mais en fait ce sont des
Boué des Boué à l'infini sous lesquels
pousse une plante au vertu
miraculeuse une plante qui est peut-être
un des aliments du futur pour l'humanité
toute
entière ce gisement d'or vert c'est de
l'algue et pour
Wang que nous accompagnons il n'y a rien
de plus simple à
culverz bout de l'algue comme ça elle va
pas s'envoler avec le vent et elle
poussera bien vers le fond comme Wang
Bing ils sont des milliers de paysans à
récolter l'algue dans cette région car
en Asie l'algue se mange c'est même un
aliment de base consommé matin midi et
soir par plus d'un milliard
d'individus c'est excellent pour la
santé
ça c'est bon bien sûr que c'est bon et
comment ça se mange comme ça qui insiste
l'algue est nourrissante mais en plus
autre avantage la faire pousser la
cultiver c'est totalement écologique
bon vous voyez c'est extra et ici les
algues ça pousse naturellement on en
récolte des millions de tonnes et pas de
souci ça respecte
l'environnement manger de l'algue un
jour chez nous en Europe ce n'est pas
une plaisanterie c'est même une des
pistes étudié très sérieusement
aujourd'hui
une nouvelle ressource écologique et
peut-être même l'une des solutions à un
problème qui nous concerne tous celui
d'une planète dont les richesses
naturelles s'épuisent et ne suffisent
déjà plus à nourrir tout le
monde toujours plus
rapide toujours plus
moderne toujours plus peuplé et surtout
toujours plus
affamé chaque jour la planète doit
nourrir 200000 nouvelles bouches ce sont
80 millions de personnes en plus chaque
année qui veulent toute manger et manger
de
[Musique]
tout fruits légumes poissons ou viande
l'explosion de la consommation touche la
plupart des pays du globe une
mondialisation qui n'est pas sans
conséquence sur notre vie car tout ce
que nous produisons pour manger a un
impact
insoupçonné sur notre
environnement tout ce que vous manger
tous les jours a plus d'impact sur la
planète que votre maison qu'il faut
chauffer éclairer et cetera ou que vos
transport même quand vous prenez l'avion
la voiture et cetera voilà ce qui nous a
mené aux quatre coins du
monde nous avons voulu comprendre
pourquoi ce que nous mangeons ici a des
répercussions là-bas
si on continue à vouloir toujours plus
d'huile de palme un jour la forêt
n'existera plus et nous disparaîtrons
avec
elle un voyage pour comprendre comment
notre alimentation c'est industrialisé à
outr on injecte un produit au bê des
hormone de croissance grâce à cela
grossissent bien plus
vite un voyage pour découvrir quelle
solution existe déjà pour s'alimenter
tout en respectant la planète c'est pas
un choix économique c'est un choix
qualitatif c'est un choix d'arriver à
donner au consommateur le meilleur
produit
possible un voyage pour explorer de
nouvelles habitudes de nouveaux systèmes
économiques imaginer pour préserver la
terre et surtout mieux
[Musique]
vivre nous on mange que des aliments qui
viennent d' côté de chez nous et ça
c'est pour
l'environnement se nourrir un enjeu
[Musique]
vital un enjeu planétaire qui pousse
aujourd'hui certains pays à chercher
toujours plus loin des terres à
cultiver nous les Indiens nous avons
récupéré ces 10000 hectares ici en
Éthiopie et nous allons les exploiter
pendant 60
ans des États-Unis à l'Indonésie de la
France jusqu'à
l'Éthiopie nous avons enquêté pour
répondre à une question
essentielle une question qui concerne
chacun d'entre
nous comment est-il possible de tous se
nourrir sans piller la
[Musique]
planète
notre voyage commence en France en forêt
de Fontainebleau par une belle journée
d'automne ce dimanche midi Corine a
décidé de profiter du beau temps pour
aller
piqueniquer
allez en route et c'est toute une
organisation car Corine n'est pas
seule elle emmène avec elle ses enfants
ses amis les enfants de ses amis au
total ils sont une trentaine à se
retrouver autour de tartes et de
salade voulez manger un boulet les
enfants sans oublier l'ingrédient
indispensable pour un piqueenique réussi
les
chips les chips pour un piquenique c'est
c'est
obligatoire n pas le choix pouroi c'est
les enfants ou
par il y a pas de piquenique sans chips
du coup à chaque fois les paquets de
chips s'accumulent sur la couverture pas
moins d'une quinzaine ce
jour-là des arômes différents et un
ingrédient un peu mystérieux il est
indiqué au dos du paquet cet ingrédient
s'appelle l'huile de palme et il est
très
utilisé
c'est ce que nous avons constaté en
démarrant notre
enquête au rayon chips plus d'un paquet
sur de contient de l'huile de
palme une huile qui laisse le
consommateur
perplexe est-ce que vous connaissez
l'huile de palme non pas du tout huile
de palme c'est une plante non je sais
pas lui qui vient
j'en jamais dégusté et pourtant cette
huile de palme nous en consommons tous
les jours sans vraiment le savoir car
aujourd'hui elle est dans presque tous
les
rayons pour s'en rendre compte nous
avons fait nos courses pour le petit
déjeuner des brioches au pépites de
chocolat pour déjeuner sur leouce un
croque monsieur une tarte salée ou un
plat cuisiné des biscuits apéritifs et
pour le dîner des pâtes
fraîches tous ces produits contiennent
de l'huile de palme il y en a aussi dans
les pâtes feuilleté les sauces les pâtes
à tartiner les confiseries les biscuit
les soupes les glaces les céréales le
pain grillé une huile de palme que l'on
retrouve même dans du lait pour
bébés alors nous avons voulu en savoir
plus sur cette huile qui se répand dans
nos aliments vous allez le voir derrière
ce simple ingrédient se cache toute une
histoire une histoire qui mêle intérêt
économique et enjeu écologique
majeur nous partons pour auagne en
Provence pourquoi cette huile est-elle
devenue le chouchou des industriels un
élément de réponse se trouve
ici la société Sibelle est spécialisée
dans la fabrication de
chips TR ligne de production des pommes
de terre Pelé découpé cuites salé à
longueur de
journée ici la fabrication des chips n'a
rien
d'artisanal combien de tonnes par an de
chips 8000 tonnes environ par an de
chips dans ces 8000 tonnes il y a les
chips que Gill ben kemon fabrique sous
sa propre marque Sibelle il utilise
alors de l'huile de tournesol pour frire
les pétales de pommes de terre mais
Gilles travaille surtout pour les
marques distributeurs casino Intermarché
systè ou encore Netto ses clients
représentent 70 % de sa
production et souvent il lui demande la
même chose produire moins cher alors
Gill n'a pas le choix il remplace
l'huile de tournesol par de l'huile de
[Musique]
palme C Cu c'est l'uile de palme qui est
injecté par les tuyaux dans la
priteuse c'est quoi l'intérêt
aujourd'hui d'utiliser l'huile de palme
pour faire des chir le prix prix
l'huile de palme est bien moins chère
c'est ça oui ou oui une huile imbattable
environ 15 % moins chè que toutes les
autres et cette huile miracle qui permet
de fabriquer moins cher voici à quoi
elle
ressemble dans son laboratoire Gill
Benkemoun en garde quelques
échantillons en fait on a plus
l'impression que c'est du sirop ça
presque c'est ça on dirait du sirop
ouais lui de palme les industriels de
l'alimentaire l'utilisent de plus en
plus dans leurs recettes c'est même
aujourd'hui la matière grasse la plus
employée au monde le problème c'est que
la plupart des entreprises
s'approvisionnent au même
endroit conséquence cette production
d'huile bouleverse l'environnement et la
vie de population entière à l'autre bout
de la
planète pour le comprendre nous partons
à des milliers de
kilomètres en Indonésie à borneéo une
île grande comme une fois et demi la
France accroché au fleuve Kayan la ville
de
palangkaraya
[Musique]
c'est ici que commence notre périple sur
l'île de
[Musique]
Bornéo le cœur de l'industrie de l'huile
de palme se trouve à 6h de
route cap au Sud à travers la campagne
indonésienne pour arriver aux portes
d'une
entreprise à l'entrée sur la pancart un
W pour
wimar un géant de l'huile de palme le
plus gros producteur de toute l'Asie du
Sud-Est et voici ce que gardent ces
hommes en
uniforme dans l'ocre de la piste de
chaque côté un seul arbre toujours le
même le palmier à
huile des
centaines des
[Musique]
milliers des
millions en fait un territoire entier
redessiné par
l'homme des hectares et des hectares
couverts de palmiers à
huile une culture intensive est massive
qui a changé la géographie et
l'environnement de cette région du
monde aujourd'hui l'Indonésie et son
voisin la Malaisie fabriquent 80 % de
l'huile de palme
[Musique]
mondiale et pour assurer la production
une armée d'ouvriers est sur le pied de
guerre 365 jours par
an
ce matinl nous avons rendez-vous à 6h au
cœur de la plantation
Willmar la journée commence toujours par
le même
cérémonial les managers en blanc
rappellent les consignes aux
ouvriers alors les 15 qui éta hier sur
la parcelle 128 de la zone
S12 vous continuez au même endroit
Domingo et pr vous vous restez sur la
zone pH et vous t faites bien attention
de planter les palmiers comme il faut et
pas n'importe comment il en reste encore
400 essayz planter au moins 250
aujourd'hui ici chaque ouvrier couvre à
lui seul 7 hectares de plantation chaque
jour et la cadence doit être
respectée vous leur demandez toujours de
produire plus
l'objectif qu'il doivent atteindre c'est
de ramasser les fruits de deux ou TR
rangé de palmiers par
jour généralement ils y arrivent mais je
le répète quand même pour que la
production baisse pas si je ne répète
pas il y en a qui travaill moins
bien c'est une façon de le mettre la
pressioni voil c'est ça et si les
managers mettent autant la pression sur
leurs ouvriers c'est parce que ce qui se
récolte ici a une immense valeur
ce fruit rouge qui pousse en grosse
grappe à quelques mètres du sol voilà
d'où vient l'huile de
palme et c'est cela que des employés
comme tomaro viennent chaque jour
cueillir tomaro a 27 ans il est venu de
Java l'île voisine pour trouver du
travail et toute la journée avec sa
longue perche il traque les meilleurs
fruits vous pouvez m'expliquer qu'est-ce
qu'il y a là c'est l'huile
ce fr il est bien rouge à
l'exérie dire qu'il
estinhuile
ded c'est gr ça
ex et pour être bien s que tomar va
ramer que les fruits les
plus tré la
solutionreise en réc il
PL gagne de l'argent en moyenne 2 € par
jour pour livrer sur le bord du chemin
sa production quotidienne de
fruit des fruits qui sont immédiatement
collectés par une armada de camion qui
sillonne sans cesse la
plantation car pour répondre à une
demande en pleine explosion et tenir les
cadences la société a tout
prévu l'huile est fabriqué directement
sur place dans ce
pressoir une usine qui tourne jour et
nuit dans un vacarme
assourdissant les fruits récoltés y sont
immédiatement
déversés ils sont bouillis dans ces
grandes citernes
écrasés filtrés pour finalement
devenir ce liquide sombre à l'odeur
pestilentielle
mais ça Harry le manager de l'usine n'en
a pas grand-chose à faire lui il n'a
qu'un seul objectif augmenter la
production
d'huile en 2 ans il l'a presque doublé
elle atteindra bientôt 100000 tonnes et
ce n'est pas prês de
s'arrêter ça c'est l'huile de palme que
nous en Europe on va
consommer oui d'abord on la raffine et
puis on l'envoie chez vous vous en
trouverez partout dans votre supermarché
g B
dans ça veut dire que c'est une C
machine cette huile pour
vous bien co pas ch à
produireir que le rendement chez il est
excellent ça rien à voir avec l'uile de
soja imagineun de palmier ça donne 10
fois plus d'huileun de soja voilà
pourquoi l'huile de palme est moin
ch ici en indonésieette huile de
abondante est considéré comme un cadeau
du ciel un cadeau en réalité tout ce
qu'il y a de plus terrestre une culture
lancé par un Français il y a presque un
siècle en 1905 Henri fauconier arrive en
Asie un pionnier écrivain un peu touch à
tout qui veut d'abord cultiver le
caoutchou puis il a l'idée avec un ami
d'importer du Congo quelques graines de
palmier à huile un arbre qui pousse
là-bas avec une facilité étonnante en
1912 il fondent en Malaisie la première
exploitation commerciale de palmier à
huile puis acquire des terres en
Indonésie le succès de cette culture ne
se démentia
pas un siècle plus tard cette région du
monde produit chaque année 40 millions
de tonnes d'huile de palme et la demande
ne cesse d'augmenter
alors des entreprises comme Willmar
étendent encore leur plantation une
expansion menée tambour battant au prix
d'un incroyable bouleversement
écologique car pour faire de la place au
palmier à huile il a fallu tailler dans
le
[Musique]
ver des tronçonneuses qui abattent des
[Applaudissements]
arbres
les uns après les
autres avec des machines
ou lors d'incendie
volontaire la forêt vierge est
ravagée un rythme
effrayant
ici à Bornéo 2 millions d'hectares
disparaissent chaque
année et sur cette île voici ce qui
s'est passé en 60
ans en 1950 la forêt vierge est partout
au fil des années elle disparaît
irréédiablement et dans 10 ans si rien
n'est fait voici ce qu'il en restera
une déforestation massive qui est
visible partout lorsque nous parcourons
le pays une déforestation qui fait
polémique car la forêt vierge est
essentielle pour notre vie pour le
comprendre nous nous rendons dans l'un
des derniers espaces préservés de ces
plantations de la forêt primaire
conservé par la société wimar sous la
pression de
l'opinion pour nous guider dans ce dédal
ver nous rencontrons Kelly une
biologiste qui vient du
zimbabweé elle a été embauché PARM pour
protéger ses
forêts une cathédrale de feuillage ronne
des bruits
étranges en quoi est important de garder
la forêt pour nous t ê
humain pour notre propre futur que nous
avons besoin de la forêt vierge c'est le
poumon du
monded cette forêt est importante pour
nous par exemple à Paris vous polluez
les voitures rejettent plein de gaz
carbonique et bien ici à l'autre bout de
la planète ces arbres capturent ses gaz
et à la place il rejettent de
l'oxygène pas le gaz de nos voitures à
Paris quand
même en fait c'est une
image à l'échelle mondiale lat prod y
vous rasz la for vous relâchez tout le
gaz carbonique dans l'air et ça augmente
le réchauffement climatique et
automatiquement ça change le climat de
la
planète et c'est bien ça le plus
préoccupant moins de forêt ça veut dire
moins d'arbre pour capturer le
co2lanter des palmiers ne suffit pas car
ce sont des plantes et non pas des
arbres ils absorbent TR fois moins de
gaz carbonique que la forêt vierge
et le CO2 est l'un des gaz à effet de
serre qui accélère le réchauffement
climatique lorsque les rayons du soleil
atteignent la planète une partie d'entre
eux est réfléchi vers le
ciel le problème c'est que le CO2
accumulé dans l'atmosphère bloque une
partie de ces rayons solaires et les
renvoie vers le sol c'est l'une des
causes de l'augmentation de la
température et donc du réchauffement
climatique
et l'Indonésie a sa part de
responsabilité ce pays est devenu l'un
des principaux producteurs mondiaux de
gaz à effet de serre en grande partie à
cause de cette déforestation
massive ces arbres si important pour
l'avenir de la planète renferme aussi
des richesses
insoupçonnées
des espèces
[Musique]
rares grande
ou
minuscule c'est typique de la forêt
vierge
ça c'est vraiment caractéristique de
voir beaucoup de fourmis ou ce type de
termite il y a une très grande
biodiversitéci m le bois les ares par
terre c'est un
écosystème tout est
lié vous avez des espèces clés dans la
forêt si vous retier l'une d'elle tout
peut s'écrouler ouis c'est évidemment
essentiel pour notre
vie le problème c'est que cette nature
dont parle Kelly est aujourd'hui
[Musique]
menacée menacée par la production
massive d'huile de palme que l'on
utilise pour fabriquer des chips comme
des centaines d'autres produits
alimentaires
car lorsque la forêt primaire est
remplacée par des palmiers des milliers
d'espèces vivantes disparaissent peu à
peu à commencé par l'une des plus
visibles Laurent
houtant il y en avait 10000 il y a 5 ans
il y en a moitié moins
aujourd'hui ces singes sont souvent tués
lorsque les
sonoup ce qui en réchapp parmi les
palmiers à huile et MEUR de
[Musique]
fa mais lors de notre voyage nous avons
découvert un autre phénomène dont nous
n'avions pas imaginé
l'ampleur aujourd'hui vous allez le voir
l'huile de palme ne met plus seulement
en périle les
animaux pour le comprendre nousons nous
à l'intérieur d'un autre
monde aujourd'hui vous allez le voir
l'huile de palme ne met plus seulement
en péril les
animaux pour le comprendre nous allons
nous
enfoncer à l'intérieur d'un autre
monde une journée de route et de piste
cabossé des heures de marche
Saco dans ce qui s'appelle ici les 12
collines nous arrivons enfin dans un des
derniers espaces de forêt vierge habités
par les
orangrimba les hommes de la
forêt Tangun est le chef de la
tribu avec sa femme et ses 17 enfants
ils habitent ses abris sommaires
il ils sont
nomades depuis des générations ils
vivent en harmonie totale avec la
nature pour les nourrissons on utilise
ces feuilles de Samoun ça les
protège on les emmaillotte dedans et ils
sont sains et
sauf il y a 64 familles ici dans un
espace de vie qui se réduit s cesse à
cause de la
déforestation et existence qui est en
jeu car moins de forêt cela signifie
moins de
nourriture
lesrimba vivent de la pêche et de la
chasse et actuellement la viande devient
de plus en plus
rare c'est de plus en plus difficile
pour moi de trouver à manger pour ma
famille avant la forêt était plus grande
c'était plus facile pour nous de chasser
il y avait plus
d'animaux que la forêt rétréciss c'est
beaucoup plus
dur pour ce cochon sauvage par exemple
il a fallu chasser plusieurs jours au
fin fond de la forêt alors qu'auparavant
quelques heures aux alentours
suffisaient désormais pour subsister les
orangrimba vendent aux hommes de la
ville ces fruits rouges utilisés pour
colorer les tissus
ou ce bois qui sert à fabriquer des
chaises ou des
tables mais aujourd'hui Tangun ne sa pas
si ses enfants pourront vivre comme lui
a vécu en homme des
forêts bien sûr qu'on est en danger
l'huile de palme c'est une menace pour
nous si les plantations de palmiers
continuent à grossir un jour la forêt
n'existera plus et nous non plus çaen
sera fini
desorrimba une menace chantée le soir
venu par les S de
tribu ils évoquent leur forêt
d'autrefois large et généreuse
désormais un vieux
[Musique]
souvenir les orangrimba parviendront-ils
à préserver leur
forêt pour cela il faudrait que la
demande en huile de palme diminue c'est
l'Europe qui en importe le plus et dans
nos médias l'huile de palme commence à
être pointé du
doigt pour des raisons environnemental
mais pas
uniquement l'huile de palme serait
également mauvaise pour notre santé
elle contient qu fois plus de mauvaise
graisse que l'huile de tournesol ou de
colza pour ces raisons nous sommes de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir diminuer
notre consommation d'huile de palme mais
encore faut-il savoir dans quelle
produit elle se trouve car en ce moment
certains industriels jouent sur
l'ambigué de retour en France nous avons
acheté plusieurs produits en théorie
rien n'indique qu'ils contiennent de
l'huile de palme sur leurs emballages
dans la liste des ingrédients il n'y a
souvent que ces quelques mots matière
grasse végétale ou bien huile
végétale et pourtant voilà ce qu'on nous
répond quand on appelle les service
consommateur service consommateur
bonjour à tous Nous leur avons posé la
même question j'ai vu que il y avait
marqué huile végétale je voulais savoir
ce que c'était exactement euh donc c'est
de l'huile de palme dans le bouillon de
poule la matière végétale ça de l'uile
de palme c'est de quel végétal cette
matière grasse végétale c'est de l'huile
de palme il y a de l'huile de palme dans
le tout à fait il y a de l'huile de
palme essentiellement on utilise de
l'huile de palme oui une huile présente
dans tous nos produits mais passer sous
silence c'est tout à fait légal la
réglementation n'oblige pas les
industriels à le spécifier sur les
paquets ce qui les arrange car cette
huile de palme devient de moins en moins
populaire auprès des
consommateurs certains tentent
d'ailleurs de faire pression sur les
industriells de
l'alimentaire c'est ce qui est arrivé à
l'entreprise anglaise
catberurry leur chocolat day milk à
l'huile de palme a été boycotté par les
consommateur en
[Musique]
Nouvelle-Zélande j'ai toujours acheté du
chocolat cbur mais depuis qu'il utilise
de l'huile de palme j'ai changé de
marque du coup l'entreprise s'est excusé
et a fait machine arrière elle a retiré
l'huile de palme de ses barres chocolaté
vendu en
Nouvelle-Zélande
mais alors nous en France pouvons-nous
également acheter des produits sans
huile de
palme notre enquête nous conduit dans le
nord de la
France à Boulogne sur Mer siège d'une
marque vieille de 60 ans très connu des
Français l'entreprise
finus le bestseller ici c'est le poisson
pané 17000 tonnes produit l'année
dernière ça ne se voit pas comme ça mais
cette usine a été le théâtre d'une
petite révolution conduite par Mathieu
Lambo le
PDG il a décidé de changer d'huile pour
cuire ses poissons il a remplacé l'huile
de palme par de l'huile de colza une
huile qui demande beaucoup plus
d'attention car il faut la changer plus
souvent et surtout la surveiller toutes
les
heures la Mané elle est plus instable
c'est plus compliqué pour vous plus
compliqué oui c'est plus compliqué ça
vous coûte plus cher ça coûte plus cher
bien sûr mais le choix de faire de l'ile
de colza par définition c'est pas un
choix économique c'est un choix
qualitatif c'est un choix d'arriver à
donner au consommateur le meilleur
produit possible donc je trouve qu'en
général malheureusement ou en général
c'est des c'est des choses qui coûtent
plus
cher pour Matthieu Lambo l'huile de cols
c'est tout de même un surcût de 3
million d'euros
entièrement à sa charge puisqu'il
n'augmentera pas le prix de ses produits
dans les
supermarchés mais ce qu'il espère c'est
rentabiliser son investissement en
augmentant ses
ventes et pour cela il doit d'abord
s'assurer que changer d'huile ne change
pas le
goût dans les bureaux de l'entreprise il
y a une cuisine
expérimentale ce jour-là une épreuve se
prépare elle est dirigée par stevenh
Liberman responsable marketing donc on
est là pour valider le dernier produit à
passer en huile de colza les crusti
Express
quartier le produit le voici tout juste
sorti du micro-ondde ce sont des pommes
de terre donc là on est en N de colza et
là c'est pas M
colza ok
allez-y ce qui est important c'est de ce
qui important c'est de juger est-ce que
vous voyez une différence de goût est-ce
que c'est un peu moins gras est-ce que
le produit est toujours aussi
crostillantf je vois pas de différence
entre les deux en tout cas même constat
pour Steven et son équipe reste
maintenant à transformmer l'opération en
machine à vendre pour cela l'argument
est bien mise en évidence sur le paquet
c'est fabriqué avec de l'huile de colza
et non de l'huile de palme en fait c'est
indiqué ici c'est ça mais un moment
donné on pas simplement pour avoir une
belle image non c'est pas une question
d'image mais c'est une question
d'éthique oui mais pas seulement c'est
aussi parce que on a le sentiment que le
consommateur va se tourner vers vous oui
oui on ambitionne une croissance de 15 %
sur les 3 ans oui
effectivement voilà pourquoi vendre des
produits écolos peut servir des intérêts
financiers l'entreprise a ainsi déjà vu
progresser ses ventes de 8 % l'année
[Musique]
dernière
le citoyen le consommateur a donc le
pouvoir de faire changer les méthodes
des
[Musique]
industrielles en faisant attention à ce
qu'il achète il peut inciter les
entreprises de l'agroalimentaire à
davantage respecter
l'environnement l'enjeu est de taille
car actuellement 80 % de ce que nous
mangeons est produit industriellement et
la tendance va enc
samplifié nous serons 7 milliards
d'humains en 2012 à vouloir manger plus
mais surtout manger la même chose du
poulet en
nuggets des saucisses industrielles
ou des yaourts aux
fruits mais l'aliment qui depuis
quelques années est devenu la star
absolue des assiettes du monde entier la
viande hachée de la vraie viande rouge
pour garder la lig c'est le bœuf ah oui
alors moi je ne mange que ça vous avez
vu pas
mal en 50 ans européens et américains
ont doublé leur consommation de viande
rien qu'en France nous avalons 350 g de
bœuf par
semaine mais aujourd'hui nous ne sommes
plus les seuls à vouloir manger de la
viande désormais tout le monde veut son
steak russe chinois pakistanais indiens
ou brésiliens sur tous les continents le
est en train de devenir l'aliment
préféré des classes moyennes le symbole
de la réussite
économique dans 40 ans la consommation
mondiale aura
[Musique]
doublé or vous allez découvrir que
produire en masse de la viande de bœuf
est l'une des activités les plus
polluantes pour notre
planète pour'endre te nous partons dans
la patrie historique du BF aux
[Musique]
États-Unis à 8000 km de Paris le
Texas dans les grandes plaines
impossible de rater
[Musique]
l'animal il vous fait saliver jusque sur
les camions qui défilent sur
[Musique]
l'autoroute
ici les habitants consomment 40 kg de
bœuf par personne et par an quatre fois
plus que la moyenne
mondiale steakhous ou fast food partout
le BFF est
[Musique]
roi c'est ici que se trouvent les plus
grands élevages du monde sous nos yeux
75000 bêtes on appelle ça des feedlots
des parcs d'engraissement
il sagit plutô d'usine à faire grossir
les vaches un système qui défie toutes
les lois de la
[Musique]
nature et ça commence dès l'arrivée du
béta chaque matin c'est le même rituel
pour lar le
manager il accueille de nouvelles
cargaisons ell viennent des qu coins des
États-Unis
vous en recevez
beaucoup ça dépend 2500 par
semaine le programme qui les attend mois
d'un régime intensif avant
l'abattoir l'arrivée elle passe sur la
balance 47000 Liv ça fait 21on c'est
beaucoup ou pas on a chargé le camion
maximum
qu vont grossir
beaucoup quand il faudra de camions au
lieu d'un seul pour
les à la tête de ce parc
CBO qui son cheval contre hélicoptère
une réussite inest dans la profession il
possède 10 par d'engraissement
auxtats-unis
dans les bureaux de cactus feeder son
entreprise les employés le voir rarement
plus d'une fois par
semaine 500 employés travaillent pour
Paul sur ses différents sites et le
patron n'a plus grandchose à faire sinon
se réjouir de l'augmentation de son
cours de
bourse en
1990 la compagnie était valorisée à 40
dollars
l'action vous voyez on a fait beaucoup
de profit et maintenant on est à 328
dollars par action on est vraiment très
fier fils d'éleveur traditionnel Paul
Engler s'est lancé dans le business il y
a 50 ans à l'époque il était l'un des
tout premiers à opter pour l'élevage
[Musique]
intensif jusqu'au années 40 avant de
partir à
les vaches ne mangeai que de l'herbe
dans de grands
espaces mais après la guerre tout a
changé la demande de viande explose
c'est la période des TR glorieuses fast
food à tous les coins de rue et
hamburger pour tous le bœf se
démocratise pour répondre à cette
demande les éleveurs comme Paul vont
inventer un nouveau mode d'élevage
Industrialis
out aujourd'hui Paul Engler doit
produire plus de 7000 tonnes de steak
par semaine pour y arriver il doit faire
grossir ses bêtes en un temps
record alors il a mis au point un
traitement de choc qui rentabilise son
bétail au maximum un traitement où la
nature cède le pas à la
science d'abord dès l'arrivée dans
l'exploitation sé de à la chaîne pour
les vaches un vaccin contre les
parasites mais surtout une injection à
base d'hormone de
croissance voici les doses qu'on injecte
au
bêtes bon ce sont essentiellement des
hormones de
croissance grâce à ces piqures les
vaches grossissent plus
vite du coup on a besoin de moins de
nourriture pour produire 1 kil de viande
de
bœuf moins de nourriture certes mais une
nourriture ultra dopante car ici les
vaches suivent un régime qui les
transforme en d'incroyable machine à
viande dans le fidelot elles nont pas
d'Herb à
Bré leur repas est entièrement fabriqué
à
l'usine
l'ingrédient principal arrive par
camion des tonnes de maïs stocké pour le
bétail or par nature les vaches ne
mangent pas de
[Musique]
céréales
qu'importe le nutritionniste n'a pas
d'état d'âme les animaux vont devoir s'y
faire on nourrit les bêtes au maïs parce
que le maïs le fait prendre du poids
beaucoup plus
vite évidemment avec leur estomac qui
est habitué à l'herbe il faut les
adapter à ce nouveau régime alors au
début on leur donne un mélange d'herbe
et de maïs et puis ensuite on passe
entièrement au
maïs mais il y a encore mieux pour
engraisser une vache dans ces machines
le maïs est transformer en un aliment
hyper calorique un aliment que nous
connaissons tous au petit-déjeuner
le
cornflex en transformant le maïs en
cornfl on augmente encore la prise de
poids de 10 à
12% les vaches sont ainsi GAV par camion
jour et nuit un régime qui leur fait
prendre plus d'un kil par jour résultat
chaque bê est prête pour l'abattoir en
seulement 18 mois au lieu de 3 ans
d'ordinaire
voilà pourquoi ce système de production
s'est exporté dans de nombreux pays en
Australie en Argentine ou au
Brésil en France le recours aux hormones
de croissance est interdit dans les
élevages en revanche plus de la moitié
des vaches qui finissent dans nos
assiettes a été nourrie avec des
céréales de manière
industrielle grâce à ces méthodes dans
les supermarchés du monde entier le prix
de la viande baisser de plus de 30 % en
ans mais fournir un steak toujours moins
cher à toujours plus de monde à un coût
écologique
gigantesque car les élevages de masse
sont extrêmement
polluants d'abord à cause de ce
qu'ingurgite le bœuf plus d'une tonne de
céréales avant d'aller à
l'abattoir or pour produire ces céréales
il a fallu parfois raser des forêts
entières asperger des champs de
pesticides puis acheminer le maïs avec
des milliers de camions qui rejettent du
dioxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère mais ce n'est pas tout une
grande part de la pollution provient de
la vache
elle-même lorsqu'elle rumine et digère
ses aliments la vache rejette un gaz
très polluant le méthane ce gaz est l'un
des plus nocifs pour la
planète au total selon l'Organisation
mondiale de l'agriculture la FAO les
élevages industriels surtout de bœuf
sont responsables de 18 % des gazs à
effet de serre émis dans le monde c'est
plus que toutes les voitures qui roulent
sur la
[Musique]
planète l'élevage de B pollue donc l'air
mais il pollue aussi les sols et cela
met directement en danger notre
santé au départ cela peut prêter à
sourire mais pour Larry le manager du
feedlot c'est un vrai
problème 75000 bêtes concentré sur une
surface réduite ça laisse des
traces est par la B vous n'imaginez pas
mais chaque animal produit environ une
tonne pendant son séjour ici une ton et
tout ça ici ça fait combien et bien rien
que dans cet enclos ça fait à peu près
200 tonnes de bous sur
l'année une vache produit 20 fois plus
d'excréments qu'un être
humain icies déjections sont déblay
régulièrement mais ce n'est pas le cas
infiltrer le sol les bouses risquent
alors d'atteindre la nappe fréatique et
la contaminer avec des hormones de
croissance des antibiotiques que l'on a
donné aux animaux mais aussi des
nitrates contenus dans les déjection or
la nappe fréatique alimente la
population en eau et cette pollution
peut avoir des conséquences dramatiques
sur la
[Musique]
santé aujourd'hui des dizaines de
milliers d'Américains sont confrontés à
ce
problème pour le comprendre nous avons
mené l'enquête tout autour de ces
élevages
intensifs direction l'état de l'Idaho
dans le nord-ouest des
États-Unis une région très rurale où les
vaches sont deux fois plus nombreuses
que les
habitants ici comme ailleurs dans le
pays les élevages ont des effets
dévastateurs sur la santé
alors face à cette menace une femme a
décidé de briser le silence
elle s'appelle
Alma alma est venu s'installer dans la
région pour la
nature mais quand chef d'entreprise a
eménagé en 2005 elle a découvert qu'elle
était entouré
deait pas de fot ce serait le paradis
ici on serait vraiment
heureux très vite avec sa fille Alma a
décidé de se mobiliser et dans le
voisinage les langues ont commencé à se
délier dans ces cartons des dizaines de
témoignages accablants à chaque fois
face au géants de l'industrie du bœuf
les familles semblent complètement
démuni les élevages s'installent souvent
dans des zones rurales pauvres et c'est
tout béf pour eux parce que les
habitants n'ont pas l'argent pour se
défendre et se payer un avocat et d'une
certaine façon il mise
là-dessus et en ce moment l'affaire qui
occupe tout son temps est un véritable
scandale
sanitaire une histoire qui met en cause
les pouvoirs
publics nous nous rendons vers le nord
de l'Idaho à
sunnyide en seulement 7 ans cette petite
localité a été
décimé 10 % des habitants sont morts
d'un cancer
un T 10 fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale pour la population il y a un
coupable en plein milieu du
village cet élevage de
BF parmi les survivants de cette écombe
les W bonjour Monsieur Merci de
nousevoir bonjour je suis pas très
présentable ça vous êtes
parfait traité habite cette maison
depuis
1990 ils travaillaient dans leur petite
station service quand ils ont vu
s'installer en bordure de leur propriété
4000 vaches c'était il y a 10 ans
aujourd'hui l'exploitation est fermée
mais elle a laissé des traces voici ce
que les wandreies voyaient depuis chez
[Musique]
eux ces images amateures ont été filmées
à l'époque par un autre voisin
les animaux vivaient dans des conditions
déplorables partant de pluie les bêtes
pataue jusqu'à la pense dans un mélange
de Bou et
d'excréments la bouse n'était jamais
évacuée résultat elle s'infiltrait dans
la nappe
fréatique et votre eau elle était
comment elle était noire on ne pouvait
pas se doucher pourire la vaisselle
c'était vraiment
dégoûtant et le comble c'est que l'état
de l'Idaho le savait les habitants nont
aujourd'hui la
preuve dans ce rapport les autorités
reconnaissent avoir fait dès 2004 des
tests sur l'eau des
habitant nitrate hormone de croissance
antibioti tous ces produits ont été
détectés il est même écrit que ces
éléments présentent des risques pour la
santé des
résidents
pourtant les riverins qui demandai la
fermeture de l'exploitation n' jamais
été écouté par les autorités
se renvo la B l'agriculture disait qu'il
fallait s'adresser à l'environnement
l'environnement disait qu'il fallait
s'adress à
l'agriculture il n on Balad pendant des
années l'État ne demander jamais de
compte à l'éleveur qui partira
finalement de lui-même parce que son
élevage n'était plus assez rentable
mais le problème c'est que la bouse elle
est toujours
là 24000 tonnes séché accumulé dans ces
anciens encloss qui 3 ans après
continuent à
[Musique]
polluer mais alors pourquoi l'État
a-t-il laissé faire c'est ce que nous
avons voulu
savoir malgré toutes nos demandes les
autorités ont refusé de nous accorder
une
interview
capitale de l'aho nous décidons alors
d'accompagner Alma au Département de
l'Agriculture nous filmons l'entretien
en caméra
cachée bonjour bonjour Madame la
Directrice je suis Alma et voici mon ami
guilagach bonjour madame mais une fois
de plus Alma ne va pas trouver une
oreille très
attentive felot continue à polluer c'est
un vrai
problème ces personnes souffrent
toujours tous les jours on sait même pas
quelles conséquences ça va avoir pour
eux à long
terme personne de votre département n'a
jamais cherché à s'informer auprès des
riverins il y a des cancers des
leucémies il y a des vrais problèmes de
santé publique et tout le monde continue
à s'en moquer ce n'est pas
justez une minute ch BR la question
d'allem reste sans réponse la directrice
appelle son adjoint à l'aide et surprise
celui-ci est courte le
rendez-vous je c que le mieux pour vous
c'est de partir là maintenant mais vous
protégez qui les citoyens ou les
éleveurs écoutez revenez plus tard vous
serez les bienvenus mais d'ici là
poussez pas trop loin il sintéresse
juste à l'environnement il est comme
moi ok j'en suis ravi mais très occupé
elle n'a pas de temps à perdre surtout
avec un touriste qui vient pour nous
critiquer quand il s'agit de parler du
bœf aux officiels de l'État nous sommes
face à un mur et selon Alma la raison
est extrêmement
simple le problème c'est que le
département de l'Agriculture a deux
casquettes son rôle c'est à la fois de
promouvoir l'industrie du bœuf et c'est
aussi de réguler les élevages et donc de
préserver l'intérêt des
citoyens il y a donc conflit d'intérêt
comment pouvez-vous défendre
correctement
l'industrie et en même temps faire
respecter les règles c'est
impossible avec ce type de
fonctionnement l'élevage intensif n'est
donc pas prêt d'être remis en
cause pourtant aujourd'hui il est
possible de consommer différemment du
bœuf élevé au grand air et nourri à
l'herbe seulement il faut y mettre le
prix en moyenne cette viande coûte 30 %
plus cher que celle qui sort des
élevages intensifs voilà pourquoi le
bœuf industriel a conquis la plupart des
assiettes du monde entier alors face au
problème écologique que cela pose
certains ont opté pour une solution
[Musique]
radicale à contrecourant de tout ce qui
se fait dans le monde il y a des endroit
en France où l'on a décidé de manger
moins de bœuf
qu'avant dans cette école parisienne par
exemple tous les mardis les enfants ont
droit à un repas un peu
spécial le plat principal est
végétarien qu'est-ce que vous servez
aujourd'hui
mesdames c'est des épinard avec des
saucisses tofou puré des saucisses quoi
pardon au tofou il y a déjà le tofu une
pâte végétale à base soja qui ce jour-là
apporte les protéines nécessaires aux
enfants une fois par semaine il n'y a
donc plus de viande sur le plateau repas
et pour l'instant les jeunes palais ont
encore un peu de mal à s'habituer à ce
changement de
régime pas bon c'est pas
bon drôle de goû ça pas le Bû de
saucisses c'est pas très B je porte moi
je trouve c'est bon les repas
végétariens mais parfois c'est un peu F
question goût il y a encore du chemin à
faire mais en mangeant moins de bœuf les
enfants prennent moins de risque d'avoir
des maladies
cardio-vasculaires c'est donc bon pour
la santé et bon pour
l'environnement voilà pourquoi ce genre
d'initiative commence à faire école un
peu partout en Europe en Angleterre en
Suède ou aux Pays-Bas mais ce mouvement
n'en est qu'à ses début car dans
l'alimentation voici la réalité à
laquelle nous sommes tous confrontés au
quotidien nourrir en masse toujours plus
de monde signifie produire en masse
toujours plus de
nourriture une alimentation industrielle
dont on vient de voir les conséquences
les plus visibles sur
l'environnement mais avec cette
alimentation mondialisée il y a un autre
coup écologique un impact que nous
consommateurs sommes parfois très loin
d'imaginer pour nous en rendre compte
nous sommes allés les yeux grand ouverts
dans un lieu qui nous est
familier mais avec cette alimentation
mondialisée il y a un autre coup
écologique un impact que nous
consommateurs sommes parfois très loin
d'imaginer pour nous en rendre compte
nous sommes allés les yeux grand ouvert
dans un lieu qui nous est
familier dans un hypermarché lorsque
nous faisons nos courses nous avons un
choix de plus en plus grand trois fois
plus de référence qu'il y a 10 ans et la
plupart des produits viennent du monde
entier pour arriver jusqu'à nos rayons
ils ont souvent fait un très long voyage
et qui dit kilomètrre dit souvent
pollution nous sommes allés faire nos
courses avec Elisabeth Laville experte
en développement durable quand les gens
expliquent pourquoi ils consomment pas
responsable al premier arrêt au rayon
fruits et
légumes à force de le consommer toute
l'année on en oublierait presque que
l'ananas est un fruit qui ne pousse qu'à
des milliers de kilomètres de chez
nous celui-là par exemple est importé
par avion c'est marqué en petit hein
mais ça c'est marqué dessus et c'est
quoi le problème ah ben le problème
c'est que l'avion a un impact
considérable 10 à 20 fois plus d'impact
que le même produit s'il pouvait être
produit localement ce qu'il avait pas
possible et quant au produits qui
poussent d'habitude dans nos campagne
mauvaise surprise ce n'est pas forcément
mieux pour l'environnement il faut avoir
l'œil sur les
étiquettes même en saison l'essentiel de
ce qu'on trouve va venir les giroles
voilà des
États-Unis la trompette de la mort de
Turquie le pied le pied de mouton de
Bulgarie il en reste quelquesuns de
France là voilà oreayon conserve c'est
encore pire car la mention de la
provenance n'est pas obligatoire
sardines des sardines conditionnées au
Maroc mais rien ne dit que ce sont les
seuls kilomètres contenus dans cette
boîte d'où vient la boîte d'où viennent
les sardines d'où vient l'huile et
cetera en pratique c'est pas indiqué sur
la boîte donc si tentez que vous vouliez
faire attention à ça c'est du coup pas
évident très vite les kilomètres
s'accumulent dans le
CAD ananas cœur de salade poivron
courgette pommes de terre champignons
sardines espadon avocat et crevettes
avec 10 produits seulement le chariot
affiche un total de 45500 km au
compteur un tour complet de la planète
et cela représente un énorme impact
écologique l'alimentation c'est la
première source d'impact écologique dans
la vie d'un individu qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par là ça veut dire que ce
que vous consommez tout ce que vous
mangez tous les jours a plus d'impact
sur la planète que votre maison qu'il
faut chauffer éclairer et cetera ou que
vos transport même quand vous prenez
l'avion la voiture et cetera donc ça
veut dire l'alimentation est plus
polluante potentiellement que n'importe
quel autre domaine de notre vie
quotidienne exactement d'autant que
derrière certains produits se cachent
des aller-retours
ahurissant exemple les
[Musique]
langoustines pêché par des chalutiers en
mer du Nord elles sont transportées par
bateau d'Europe
jusqu'en Thaïlande pour être décortiqué
par une main d'œuvre peu chère ensuite
ell repartent dans l'autre sens pour
arriver dans nos rayons total
aller-retour 20000
[Musique]
km pour enrayer cette inflation
kilométrique certains ont décidé de se
mobiliser étonnamment c'est au pays du
fast food que ça se passe aux
États-Unis
nous sommes sur la côte ouest au bord du
Pacifique à San Francisco la ville de
toutes les
[Musique]
mutations après les révolutions IPI gay
ou
hightech aujourd'hui c'est le green
business qui déferle sur la baie le
retour à la terre en quelque sorte dans
une ville où beaucoup font attention à
leur ligne et à leur santé l'heure est à
la guerre au kilomètres dans
l'assiette et le combat commence ici sur
le marché fermier du ferry Plaza devenu
aussi prisé que le Golden Gate ou
alcatraas chaque semaine c'est là que se
retrouve ce que l'on appelle les locavor
rien à voir avec l'esprit babacol des
années 60 ici être locavor c'est très
tendance c'est important pour
l'environnement la santé et pour le goût
en achetant des produits du coin vous
savez que vous soutenez le commerce
local c'est un mouvement très important
ici dans la baie de San Francisco et on
est tous sur la même longueur
d'onde le mouvement est né en 2001 un
écologiste américain décide alors de
mener une expérience ne manger que ce
qui pousse autour de chez lui son récit
devient un bestseller dans tout le pays
et lance la mode des loc avor le
principe est le suivant ne manger que
des produits qui ont voyagé moins de 150
miles soit 240 km les produits de ce
stand par exemple viennent d'un range à
150 km
d'ici ces prunes ont poussé dans un
village à 190 km de San Francisco ici
tout est produit en Californie du coup
pas de café pas de mangue pas de
camambber de Normandie et malgré cela le
marché fait le plein toutes les semaines
et sus sucite des
vocations c'est le cas par exemple d'un
jeune Français Benoît débarqué ici il y
a 6 ans pour tenter l'aventure du local
business en
Californie à la base une idée simple que
lui a soufflé sa femme américaine un
yaourt à l'ancienne fait avec des
ingrédients 100%
locaux
alors on en a la fraise à la mytille au
citron le miel et tous les fruits de ces
yaourts c'est ici sans autres transport
additionnel que benoî les récupère en
main propre chaque
semaine en quelques années son yaourt s
fait un nom et son stand ne désempli pas
cé local bio le packaging et puis le com
on dit la French Touch côté qui
inferment français que c'est ptit peu
plus doux ça ça aussi différencie le le
produit d'ici la fin de la journée
Benoît aura vendu 500 yaourt la demande
de produits fabriqués dans la région ne
cesse d'augmenter actuellement en
Californie le modèle local est en pleine
essort la plupart des grandes surfaces
se sont lancées sur le
créneau mais il y en a une qui surpasse
toutes les
autres hfood une chaîne d'hypermarché
bio créée dans les années 80 c'est là
que benoî écoule près de la moitié de sa
production 120 points de vend dans le
nord de la Californie désormais le
saint-benoî est en tête de gondole avec
en prime la photo du producteur souriant
naturel et bien entendu
local mais des fabricants comme Benoît
ça ne se trouve pas si facilement alors
pour s'approvisionner l'enseigne doit
sans cesse traquer les meilleurs
producteurs de la région
[Musique]
pour cela elle envoie sur le terrain des
têtes chercheuses comme
AR ce prospecteur passe son temps à
quadriller le nord de la Californie 650
km en moyenne chaque
semaine ce jourl a rendez-vous avec un
éleveur de la région qui produit des ufs
et qui l'intéresse énormément car pour
l'instant il n'a pas de fournisseur à
moins de 2600 km d'ici il y a une grosse
demande pour les œufs de poule élevés en
plein air en ce moment je pense qu'il
peut vraiment devenir un gros
fournisseur pour les magasins du nord de
la baie donc je vais le rencontrer voir
quel est le potentiel de sa ferme et
Sion peut travailler
ensemble des fr à seulement 50 km de San
Francisco voilà ce que espère trouver
ici dans la ferme de
Don he salut don je suis content de te
connaître moi aussi salut don est la 4e
génération de fermiers de sa famille un
début de carrière dans l'immobilier puis
à 28 ans il a repris l'exploitation
familiale à la retraite de ses parents
c'était il y a 9 ans outre l'élevage de
mouton il vient de relancer la
production de poule que pratiquaient ses
aïoles photo d'époque à l'appui
regardez-moi ça c'est une photo de mon
père mon oncle et mon grand-père il y a
environ 65 ans à l'époque ils élevaient
des poules ici don compte beaucoup sur
cette visite mais avant de faire affaire
le représentant de Hall foods veut
inspecter l'exploitation de
fontanc tu les fait tourner tes poules
de temps en temps tu les changes de
pâturage ouis oui je viens juste de le
faire d'ailleurs les poules sont élevées
en liberté mais cela ne suffit pas
selon dis donc le bec de tes poules il a
été coupé et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
ne veut pas de poule avec des bec coupés
car selon lui c'est généralement le
signe des poules élevé en
batterieen don
s'adaptera si tu veux je peux commander
des poules s coup c'est pas un problème
ok pas coup
becicorétionation
bi lour à remplir pour ce jeune
agriculteur mais si don se plie aussi
docilement à toutes les conditions de
Food c'est parce qu'il y a un gros
marché à la clé 120 magasins dans toute
la Californie du Nord où vivent 10
millions de personnes c'està-dire 100
millions de consommateurs
potentiel je veux juste m'agrandir parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de demande en ce
moment mais cette demande est
nouvelle
l'argent
chéri ce typ doit nourrir sa famille il
doit nourir
luiêmeire son
hérit Mo j'espère bien développer
m'aider donc March concl Mar
concl il pourra fournir à Harve chaque
semaine 200 douzaines d' l'enseigne les
vendra ensuite 8 dollars la douzaine
c'est deux fois plus cher que des œufs
industrielles mais cette formule
peut-elle marcher partout dans le monde
aussi bien qu'à San
Francisco peut-on être locavor n'importe
où en France là où tout ne pousse pas
aussi facilement que dans cette baie
miraculeuse
pour le savoir direction le Bassin
parisien à la rencontre des locavor
[Musique]
Français nous sommes à FONTEN sousbois
loin de San Francisco et des millions de
dollars que génère le local
food ici l'économie locale c'est lui
jeanluc Morau agriculteur dans la
marnees semaines il livre en personne
les 500 kg de légumes qu'il a récolté le
matin sur son exploitation pour
ravitailler les locavor de Fontenet là
j'arrive de brous ilgr dans la Marne
donc j'amène mes légumes pour la map de
Fontenis la map ce n'est pas un marché
c'est l'association pour le maintien
d'une agriculture paysane un groupement
de consommateurs comme il y en a 1200 en
France ce jour-là dans son camion des
brocolis des épinards et une petite
originalité de
cette semaine la nouveauté ça va être le
petit marron parce que on approche
d'Halloween et puis la course
traditionnellement arrive à l'automne
donc bon les gens apprécient la la
diversification dans le panier donc le
petit marron c'est intéressant de amener
maintenant quoi ces petits marrons et
tous les autres légumes les adhérents
les ont achetés en début d'année
lorsqu'ils ont réglé leur cotisation 19
€ par mois bonjour ça va bien ça va toi
ce sont les adhérents également qui
assurent la distribution des
légumes on a 60 paniers d'cord 60 petit
paniers 48 grand on est donc loin des
linéaires de H foods en Californie car
en France le modèle locavor n'en est
qu'au stade
associatif Sébastien par exemple est
adhérant de la map de fonna depuis le
tout début il y a 2 ans comme lui ils
sont une centaine à venir tous les
jeudis c Leir à l'avance ce qu'ils vont
y trouver une Pete surprise à chaque
fois donc voil alors on est parfois un
peu circonspect demant faire
mais maïs pas l'abit cuisine mas on deme
comment va
faire par
exempag
labitud cuisiner donc cela nous a permis
de découvrir légum
le panier va devoir nourrir toute la
famille pendant une semaine Sébastien
Mia verra
etor attention livraison suivante jeudi
prochain en attendant il faudra faire
avec ça des
épinard qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est
quoiinard des épinards non c'est pas
ép une courgette courgette énorme ça
qu'est-ce que c'est ça le marron le
marron c'est un petit marron ou c'est
vrai le gros avantage c'est que les
produits de la map n'ont pas voyagé
comme ces tomates auquel la famille
locavor va faire un sort au
dîner steak de tomat rien à voir donc
avec la plupart des légumes de
supermarché du jour quasiment quoi
donc vous voyez la différence on Pasi de
pas subi de de congélation enfin en tout
cas de conservation es ont été cuilles
juste à
maturité ça fait pas mal de
différence sur la table ce soir crudité
et puré de pomm de terre de la map et
cabillot du marché des menus frais des
légumes de saison mais une fois l'hiver
venu les repas deviennent un peu
monotones faut manger du chou quoi faut
manger du choufleur faut manger des
betteraves l'année dernière on a
overdose de betterave au bout d'un
moment ça lasse il y a eu des rad aussi
que c'était on
est qu'on pas le choix les légumes donc
on on prend ce qu'on nous donne malgré
ses petits inconvénients la version
française des locavor fait ses preuves
déjà 60000 familles adeptes en
France mais aelà des produits frais on
faire le reste de ces courses en prenant
en compte
l'environnement au quotidien la plupart
des Français s'approvisionnent dans les
supermarchés leurs critères de choix le
prix la qualité le goût et depuis peu la
planète avec cet indicateur
vert l'indice carbone c'est casino le
premier qui l'a mis en place un
indicateur qui mesure la quantité de gaz
carbonique c'est-à-dire de gaz à effet
de serre émis lors de la fabrication des
produits prenez par exemple ce paquet de
brioche sur l'étiquette on peut lire 315
g de
CO2 pour ce paquet de fromage râpé
l'indice grimpe à 1190 g de gaz
[Musique]
carbonique mais alors comment
calcule-t-on un indice
carbone pour le mesurer un cabinet
indépendant additionne chaque émission
de CO2 de la fabrication à la
distribution d'un
produit exemple avec cette plaquette de
chocolat
noir pour 100 g de produits la culture
du cacao en Afrique et celle de la
betterva sucre en Europe auront émis 47
g de gaz
[Musique]
carbonique le transport des matières
premières jusqu'à l'usine 41
g la fabrication de la plaquette la
phase la moins polluante 17
g les différents emballages 36
g enfin la phase la plus polluante
l'acheminement de la plaquette de
l'usine jusqu'aux différents magasins
g total 320 g de carbone émi pour une
tablette l'équivalent de 2 km en 4
[Musique]
4 aujourd'hui pour certains hypermarchés
tout l'enjeu est donc de faire baisser
l'impact carbone de leurs
produits nous partons pour le centre de
la France dans la région
lyonnaise c'est ici que se trouve le
fabricant de chocolat vendu sous la
marque
casino ce jour-là le distributeur a
envoyé dans l'usine Corine Mercadier la
spécialiste de l'indice carbone de
l'enseigne sa mission pousser son
fournisseur à être plus écologique dans
sa façon de produire du chocolat mais
pour y arriver elle va devoir se montrer
convaincante auprès du
fabricant
prods Corine Mercadier a listé une
dizaine de points à améliorer comme la
question de la distance parcourue par
les matières premières exemple le sucre
j'ai regardé au niveau des des
kilomètres vous avez TR fournisseurs
d'ingrédients pour du sucre à base de
better est-ce que ce serait possible de
travailler majoritairement avec celui
qui est plus
prez trop risqué selon le
fabriant extr sensible chez nous parce
inrédients princip du chocolat on est
oigé d'assurer desovisionn dans
différents fournisseurs pour s de
pasureapovisionnement pas de sucre pas
de chocolat l'argument est imparable pas
question de mettre en péril la
production même au nom de la protection
de la planète casselan tien Corine
Mercadier suggère d'autres pistes à
explorer utiliseer par exemple du papier
recyclé pour emballer le chocolat
imprimer directement le code barre sur
l' tui pour économiser des étiquettes ou
encore diminuer l'épaisseur d'un carton
pour en consommer moins le fournisseur
veut bien tout étudier à une condition
une seule que ça ne lui coûte pas plus
cher est-ce que sinon vous seriez tenté
d'augmenter le prix du produit c'est
toute la problématique parce que si on
on fait des améliorations
environnementales sur les produits et ça
ça provoque des augmentation de cûp
derrière il est possible que on ne soit
plus forcément concurrentiel par rapport
à d'autres d'autres fournisseurs de
chocolat voilà donc la difficulté
d'intégrer la dimension écologique quand
on fait du chocolat mais le fabricant va
devoir s'y plier car la grande enseigne
va de plus en plus prendre en compte
l'environnement dans le choix de ses
fournisseurs si je suis un fabricant de
chocolat comme
même qualité de produit et eux
travaillent sur l'environnement et pas
moi il aura des chances supplémentaires
vous commanderai davantage les produits
de ces messieurs qui font mon niveau je
vais travailler de façon privilégiée
avec le fournisseur qui fait des
efforts comme ce fabricant de chocolat
des industriels commencent à faire des
efforts et des produits à faible impact
environnemental apparaissent peu à peu
sur le marché mais encore très peu de
consommateurs on la possibilité de les
acheter à l'échelle du globe cela reste
même une infime
minorité car pour la plus grande partie
de la population mondiale l'enjeu
alimentaire est tout autre nous sommes
de plus en plus nombreux sur terre et la
planète elle arrive de moins en moins à
fournir dans certains pays cela a même
pris une dimension tragique une pénurie
qui provoque parfois violence et révolte
printemps 2008 le monde découvre des
émeutes sans
[Applaudissements]
précédent Sénégal Haïti Vietnam Égypte
ils sont des centaines de milliers à
descendre dans la rue car ils ont
faim des émeutes qui seront réprimé dans
le
[Applaudissements]
sang
pour faire face à cette pénurie
alimentaire certains pays ont trouvé la
solution partir à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez eux à la conquête
d'espace vierge pour les
[Musique]
cultiver dans le monde se joue
actuellement une gigantesque partie de
Monopoly principaux joueurs les Chinois
les indiens ou les Saoudiens qui manque
de terre cultivable leur cible des pays
pauvres qui proposent de leur louer des
terrains il en a partout en
Asie mais aussi à l'autre bout du globe
en Amérique
latine et surtout en
Afrique un pays qui attire en ce moment
toutes les
convoitises c'est l'Éthiopie cela peut
sembler paradoxal car pour la plupart
d'entre nous l'Éthiopie ça évoque
d'abord
[Applaudissements]
ça
We Are The World une chanson destinée en
1985 à récolter des dons pour
l'Éthiopie avec ce tube le monde entier
découvre alors un pays en train de
mourir de
fa la famine fait un million de morts
dont des centaines de milliers
d'enfants les images de l'épo des
paysages
des terres sèches et arides mais
l'Éthiopie offre aussi un autre visage
totalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
inattendu vue du ciel on dirait la
[Musique]
bosse des millions d'hectares de terre
vertes et fertiles cultivé de manière
par la population voilà ce qui attire
les
étrangers et pour découvrir comment ils
investissent et exploitent ces terr nous
nous dirigons vers l'ouest dans l'oromia
une des régions agricoles du
pays Baco une petite ville situé à 2300
m
d'altitude c'est ici que trouveun des
plus gr
une entreprise
indienne il est 6h du matin nous avons
rendez-vous avec un homme qui s'appelle
r c'estun des managers de la ferme
bonjour Est-ce que Monsieur s'il vous
plaît est arriv d'ind
avrer ind
ici on a du mal à croire qu'on est en
Éthiopie même le petit-déjeuner n' rien
de local qu'est-ce que
c'est du curry à 6h30 du
matin au menu du curry de pomme de terre
très
épicé ça c'est ça
réveille à 5000 km de chez lui Raz a le
mal du pays les chaînes de télé indienn
lui permettent de garder contct avec
l'Inde là-bas il a d laisser femm et
enfant il ne les voit que pour les
grandes
vacances ça c'est votre
chambre dans sa chambre il garde
précieusement un album photo un
réconfort dans les moments
difficiles c'est votre femme et vos de
enfants j'imagine qu'il vous
manque il m'appelle tous les
matins depuis combien de temps vous les
avez pas
vu depuis juillet et la prochaine fois
que je les verrai c'est en mai ah vous
ne les aurez pas vu pendant presque un
an ouais mais c'est mieux pour
l'éducation des
enfants si Razak est prêt à de tels
sacrifices c'est qu'un riche
propriétaire indien lui a confié une
mission importante faire pousser en
Éthiopie du maïs du riz et des légumes
pour se rendre sur cette air c'est tout
un péril Razak doit faire une heure de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tracteur cette route de fortune c'est
son entreprise qui l'a construite en
plein milieu des
champs son terrain est tellement grand
qu'il lui faut toute la technologie
moderne pour se
repérer vous avez besoin d'un GPS pour
vous repérer
ouais vous voyez c'est là qu'on est
exactement
ici en Inde le deuxème pays le plus
peuplé au monde le patron de Razak ne
trouvait pas de terre disponible alors
c'est en Éthiopie qu'il a tenté sa
chance et il a gagné le
[Musique]
grosot tout ça est à vous 11000 hactares
une surface
gigantesque toutes ces terres au nord
elles sont à nous
sur ces terre Razak prévoit de planter
des céréales et des légumes la majorité
de la production sera exporté vers
l'Inde et l'Asie combien vous avez
acheté ces
TER en fait on les loue au gouvernement
éthiopien c'est un bail très
long combien de temps aux alentours de
60 ans 60 ans ouais
c'est beaucoup ouais c'est beaucoup mais
pour développer tout ça il faut du temps
on peut pas réussir en 5
[Musique]
ans et combien ça coûte ici le
loyer je peux pas trop vous
répondre il faut poser la question au
patron c'est c'est un peu
compliqué non non c'est pas compliqué
non Razak est un peu gêné par la
question il faut dire que le loyer est
dérisoire 3 € par an et par hectare
l'une des terres les moins chères de la
planète voilà donc ce qui incite
beaucoup d'étrangers à venir planter
dans ce
pays maïs saoudien vigne française
fraise israélienne
on vient du monde entier pour profiter
des promotions éthiopiennes et cela
tombe bien l'état qui est propriétaire
des terres se montre généreux d'ici 5
ans il va distribuer 2 millions
d'hectares aux investisseurs sur ces
terr Razak lui a décidé de miser sur
l'une des céréales les plus cultivé en
Inde mais aussi l'une des plus
rentables alors il est
commentis ouis ça va ça va être une
bonne
récolte c'est à l'intérieur de ces
grandes herbes vertes que murissent les
grainseris une céréale très demandée qui
constitue la base de l'alimentation de
la moitié de l'humanité à terme la ferme
indienne compte produire 5 millions de
tonnes de riz en Éthiopie destination
l'Inde le reste de l'Asie et même
l'Europe la demande de nourriture va
exploser il y a pas assez de terre
disponible
et on a besoin de plus en plus de
nourriture pour
vivre avec un tel marché notre projet va
être
énorme et je pense que d'ici quelques
années nous serons sinon le plus grand
en tout cas l'un des plus grands groupes
agroalimentaires du
monde l'entreprise indienne vient
d'ailleurs d'obtenir du gouvernement
supplémentaires
pour cultiver des surfaces aussi grandes
les Indiens se sont équipés une
trentaine de tracteurs directement
importés des
États-Unis tout reste à faire la plupart
des terres sont encore complètement
vierg Raz s donné 6 mois pour tout
planter à quelques mètres des
pelleteuses les villageois continue à
faire ptre leur bétail comme ils le font
depuis toujours mais bientôt ils V devo
on tolère les villageois car ici on ne
cultive pas encore mais c'est la
dernière saison ça c'est la dernière
saison pour ou on leur a demandé de
partir
après Raz n'a pas d'état d'â c'est la
règle du jeu en Éthiopie quand les
investisseurs étranger
s'installle les paysans doivent souvent
leur céder la
place
pour nous rendre compte du
bouleversement que cela entraîne
direction
bachara un village proche de la
[Musique]
plantation ici depuis l'arrivée des
Indiens certains paysans ont été expulsé
c'est le cas de Tafari ce jeune
fermier il n'a que 18 ans mais déjà de
enfants derrière maison il nous un petit
lopin de terre où il fait pousser du
maïs tout ça c'est à
vous un demi heectar c'est tout ce qu'il
lui reste 20 fois moins que ce qu'il
cultivait
avant ça vous suffit pour vivre non je
travaille dur mais ce n'est pas assez
pour nourrir ma
famille je vais devoir vendre de vaches
pour acheter de la nourriture et essayer
de
tenir quand il avait ses terres Tafari
vendait ses récoltes sur le marché et
vivait beaucoup mieux mais depuis 6 mois
à la place de son ancien champ il y a ce
grand bâtiment c'est la plantation des
Indiens là-bas c'était mon terrain
j'avais 10 hectares je cultivais du TEF
et du sésame et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi vous avez perdu votre
terre le gouvernement nous interdit de
cultiver ici on nous dit que ça
appartient aux Indiens
maintenant comme lui une centaine de
villageois cultiv C TER depuis
génération pour les expulser le
gouvernement a trouvé un prétexte un
impôt qu'il ne leur avait jamais réclamé
auparavant les autorités sont venus nous
voir et nous ont dit mot pour mot vous
ne payez pas de taxes donc ce n'est plus
votre terrain maintenant c'est celui des
investisseurs
étrangers nous on leur a proposé de
payer les taxes mais ils nous ont dit
non c'est trop tard soudain l'interview
prend une autre tournure derrière nous
s'approche un homme armé d'une
kalashnikov il fait partie du service
d'ordre de la ferme
indienne mais pourquoi avez-vous une
arme on protège les Indiens il y a des
villageois qui les ont menacé avec des
cailloux et des
machettes très vite un attroupement se
forme face à face ceux qui ont accepté
de travailler avec les Indiens et ceux
qui ont perdu leur terre à cause d'eux
tous habitent pourtant le même
village vous seriez prêt à tuer
quelqu'un de votre
communauté non mais si quelqu'un
s'approche je tirerai en l'air on le
capturera et il ira en
prison entre les deux camps le ton
monte pourquoi tu travailles pour eux il
P bien au moins non je gagne pas
beaucoup mais j'ai pas le choix il n'y a
pas de travail dans la
région mais est-ce que ça a vraiment
amélioré ta
vie très peu mais j'ai des enfants à
nourrir moi il vaut mieux avoir un petit
travail que rien du tout tu crois pas
l'emploi un argument repris par tous
ceux qui défendent l'implantation des
étrangers en Éthiopie deux personnes sur
trois sont au
[Musique]
chômage alors devant les fermes dans les
villages nous sommes toujours témoins de
la même scène des centaines d'hommes et
de femmes venus des campagnes alentour
espérant être embauché pour la journée
certains attendent ici plusieurs jours
sans
[Musique]
manger on n pas de travail on n pas
d'argent on a faim nous personne ne nous
embauche nous on veut travailler pour
les étrangers on veut plus être
chôeur c'est une bonne chose pour le
pays qu'il viennent comme ça on aura du
travail et on gagnera notre
vie et justement sur la plantation des
Indiens Razak lui donne du
travail 300 personnes employées
actuellement 1200 lors des prochaines
récoltes la plupart n'a aucune
qualification celui-là là il est trop
court donle il faut que ça fasse au
moins 12 ou 13 cm là
ouais comme ça mais l'avantage pour
Razak c'est que cette main d'œuvre non
qualifiée est très bon marché
jusqu'à 50% moins cher qu'en
Inde doucha par exemple elle a 15 ans
elle a arrêté l'école pour aider sa
famille
8h par jour elle enlève les mauvaises
herbes autour des plantations elle gagne
l'équivalent de 11 € par mois selon elle
c'est très peu même en
Éthiopie je pourrais gagner plus
d'argent ailleurs j'ai travaillé dans
une autre ferme qui P plus
pour fa ex le même
[__] mais alors pourquoi vous restez là
et vous ne travaillez pas ailleurs cette
autre ferme est très loin et je devais
beaucoup marcher celle-ci est tout près
de ma maison j'aime travailler ici mais
je voudrais payer
plus elle dit qu'elle aime son job mais
que vous payez pas
assez mais personne n'est jamais content
de son salaire tout le monde veut
plus Dansette R is il y a pas de travail
nulle part nous on en
donne si elle était domestique elle
gagnerait plus d'argent c'est
sûr mais qui va lui donner du travail
ici les
villageois faute de mieux doucha reste
travailler chez les Indiens un emploi
qui pour l'instant ne change pas
grandchose à ses conditions de
vie la jeune fille habite à 1 he à pied
plantation dans une maison
traditionnelle la vache seul bien de la
famille trône dans le salon au total ils
sont neuf à vivre
ici le comble c'est que pour le repas du
soir doucha prépare des légumes qui ne
viennent pas de la plantation où elle
travaille nous on est employé par les
Indiens on mange pas ce qu'on
cultive parce que ce n'est pas vendu en
Éthiopie de toute façon ce serait trop
cher par rapport à ce que je
gagne et c'est là le paradoxe l'état
donne toujours plus d'hectar aux
étrangers mais n'exige pas que les
employés éthiopien soit mieux payé
résultat beaucoup ne parviennent pas à
vivre 25 ans après grand
plus de 5 million de personnes ne
subsistent encore que grâce à l'aide
alimentaire l'Éthiopie vient même de
demander en urgence 80 million d'euros à
la communauté
internationale mais alors pourquoi
brader des terres aux étranger si on
narrive pas à nourrir suffisamment son
peuple pour trouver une réponse nous
nous rendons à
addisabeba la capitale le siège du
pouvoir
officiellement le pays est aujourd'hui
une démocratie officiellement seulement
car en réalité il s'agit d'un régime
autoritaire l'un des plus sévères
[Musique]
d'Afrique nous avons rendez-vous avec le
ministre de
l'agricultureara
Derb bonjour merci de nous recevoir
Monsieur le Ministre c'est lui qui
attribue les terres aux étrangers
d'un côté vous avez plus de 5 millions
de personnes qui dépendent de l'aide
alimentaire et de l'autre vous bradez
vos terr aux investisseurs étrangers
pourquoi vous faites
ça justement on va moins dépendre de
l'aide alimentaire grâce aux étrangers
c'est grâce à ces fermes que des
millions de paysans vont s'en sortir ça
va améliorer la qualité de vie des gens
notre seule richesse ce sont nos
terres alors on fait quoi on attend que
nos paysans développent ces terres d'ici
30 à 40 ans ou alors on les cultive dès
maintenant grâce aux
étrangers c'est important que cette
terre soit cultivée le plus vite
possible mais quand on l'interroge sur
le sort des paysans expulsés sans aucune
indemnisation de l'État voici ce qu'il
répond on vous a mal renseigné vous êtes
allé voir une poignée de fermiers qui se
plaignent et qui sont paresseux et qui
ne travaillent pas assez c'est peut-être
pour cela qu'on leur donne rien parce
qu'ils sont
inefficaces donc les paysans qui se
plaignent sont feignants c'est ce que je
crois
oui j'ai rencontré des paysans
éthiopiens qui ne sont pas feignants et
qui gagnent la plupart du temps 11 € par
mois et qui n'arrivent pas à vivre avec
ça ma question sans vous manquer de
respect est la suivante ne pensez-vous
pas que vous êtes en train de laisser
les étrangers exploiter votre peuple non
on ne laisse pas notre peuple se faire
exploiter on essaie de créer des
emplois vous ne voulez pas imposer un
salaire minimum comme c'est le cas dans
la plupart des pays du
monde laissons le marché décidé le prix
de la main
d'œuvre avec cette politique
volontariste l'Éthiopie espère devancer
ses voisins et devenir le pays africain
le plus populaire auprès des
[Musique]
investisseurs c'est sur ces terres
éthiopiennes que s'achève notre
voyage un voyage à la découverte d'une
alimentation
mondialisée à l'échelle planétaire
nourrir chacun d'entre nous est donc un
défi qui soulève des questions bien plus
complexes que nous ne l'imaginions
[Musique]
pourtant dès maintenant le citoyen peut
agir souvent grâce à quelques règles de
bon
sens comme par exemple privilégier les
produits de saison et les aliments
bio certaines initiatives aujourd'hui
marginales devrait se banaliser et
offrir au consommateurs de vraies
alternatives
[Applaudissements]
comme casino la plupart des grandes
enseignes prévoient d'afficher l'impact
environnemental sur leurs produits d'ici
[Musique]
2012 Findus a banni l'huile de palme de
ses produits d'autres grandes marques
sont aussi à la recherche d'huile
meilleure pour la santé et pour
l'environnement certaines cantines
suppriment la viande une fois par
semaine d'autres se mettent au bio sous
la pression des parents
ca concernera une école sur 4 d'ici 3
ans les locavor compte de plus en plus
d'adeptes en France ils sont 15% de plus
cette année à préférer des légumes et
des fruits de saison produit à proximité
de chez
eux selon les Nations Unies si nous
appliquions ce type de solution très
concrète la Terre aurait la capacité de
nourrir 12 milliards d'individus presque
le double de ce que compte aujourd'hui
[Musique]
l'humanité